A
ON CAPITOL HILL. THANKS SO MUCH
NOW I WANT TO BRING IN
CONGRESSMAN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN KEN BUCK OF COLORADO
AND CONGRESSMAN YOU HAVE BEEN
VERY CONSISTENT IN YOUR
OPPOSITION TO GUN CONTROL
LEGISLATION. BOSTON VERY
CONSISTENT INTO WHAT YOU BELIEVE
SHOULD BE THE FOCUS IN THE WAKE
OF TRAGEDIES LIKE THIS PRIMARILY
ON THE ISSUE OF MENTAL HEALTH
AND TRYING TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES, AND I'M INTERESTED GIVEN
THE FACT THAT THE SHOOTER IN
THIS CASE AH, I WAS SEEING A
DOCTOR DUE TO MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES, WAS STILL ABLE TO
PURCHASE SEVEN GUNS FROM FIVE
SHOPS LOCALLY AND CARRY OUT THIS
CRIME. THIS MURDER. WHAT DO YOU
THINK SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE IN
THIS SITUATION? WHAT COULD
PREVENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
WELL IN COLORADO. FIRST OF ALL,
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT FEDERAL
ACTION AT IN CONGRESS, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL SOLUTION. WE HAVE A VERY
DIVERSE COUNTRY THE NEEDS FOR
AREAS OF LOS ANGELES ARE MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THE NEEDS FOR
RURAL COLORADO. SO WE HAVE A WE
HAVE PROPOSED AND STATE BY
STATE. LIMITATIONS ON ON GUN
RIGHTS IN COLORADO, WE HAVE A
RED FLAG LAW. AND A MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL CAN NOTIFY
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT SOMEBODY IS
DANGEROUS. A NEIGHBOR RELATIVE
CAN NOTIFY LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
SOMEBODY IS DANGEROUS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS MANDATED TO MOVE
THAT DOESN'T STOP GUN VIOLENCE
AND IN COLORADO, AND IT WON'T
THE BOTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES, AND WE
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THOSE WHO NEED
THAT HELP. THE GUN ITSELF ISN'T
CREATING THE CRIME, THE PERSON
BEHIND THE GUN AND THOSE PEOPLE
ARE IDENTIFIABLE. I'VE TALKED
TO. I BROUGHT SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENTS TOGETHER AND
SAID, WHAT IS THE SOLUTION? AND
THEY KNOW WHO THE DANGEROUS
STUDENTS ARE IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
AND YET THERE ARE IMPEDIMENTS
FOR THOSE SCHOOLS SUPERINTENDENT
FOR THOSE SCHOOL PRINCIPALS TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION TO
PROTECT THE STUDENTS IN THOSE
SCHOOLS, BUT I THINK THAT THIS
KIND OF GETS MY QUESTION BECAUSE
I WAS I WASN'T ASKING ABOUT THE
GUNS SPECIFICALLY HERE. THIS WAS
AN INDIVIDUAL THAT HAD KNOWN
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WAS SEEING
A DOCTOR FOR THOSE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND YET WAS ABLE TO GET
ACCESS TO GUNS TO USE. AND
YOU'RE SAYING RED FLAG LOGS AND
COLORADO? YOU'VE OPPOSED RED
FLAG LAWS, GENERALLY,
PARTICULARLY NATIONAL SCALE IN
THE PAST WOULDN'T WORK, SO THOSE
THINGS DON'T NECESSARILY NET OUT
. HOW? WHAT'S YOUR ANSWER HERE,
THEN? WELL MY ANSWER IS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE LAW IS IN
TENNESSEE. IF YOU'RE TELLING ME
THERE'S NO RED FLAG LAWS, I
DON'T OPPOSE RED FLAG LAWS THAT
GIVE DEFENDANTS IN THIS CASE THE
GUN OWNER THE RIGHT TO APPEAR IN
COURT AND DEFEND THEMSELVES. THE
PROBLEM. THE GUN, THE RED FLAG
LONG COLORADO IS THERE IS NO DUE
PROCESS. THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS ARE MANDATED TO GO
TAKE THE GUNS, WHICH IS
DANGEROUS TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
DANGEROUS TO THE INDIVIDUAL. GO
AND TAKE THE GUNS FROM THE
PERSON AND THEN THE PERSON HAS
THE BURDEN OF PROVING THEIR
INNOCENCE. THAT'S A PROBLEM
PROPERLY, UH, DEFINED RED FLAG
LAW. I WOULD BE IN FAVOR OF IF
IT GAVE THE GUN OWNER THE RIGHT
TO DEFEND THEMSELVES AND PRESENT
THEIR ARGUMENTS IN COURT. YOU
KNOW, THE PRESIDENT HAS ONCE
AGAIN REITERATED HIS CALL FOR A
REINSTATEMENT OF THE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BAN. YOU KNOW, BACK IN
2020. YOU WENT VIRAL. YOU POSTED
THIS VIDEO AFTER A SIMILAR PLEA.
TAKE A WATCH. MESSAGE FOR JOE
BIDEN. INVALUABLE WORK. IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE EVERYONE'S AR 15 IN
AMERICA, YOU SWING BY MY OFFICE
IN WASHINGTON, D C AND START
WITH THIS ONE. COME AND TAKE IT.
LOOK, I COME FROM A PLACE WHERE
ALL MY FRIENDS HAVE GONE AS MANY
OF THEM USE A R S. I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS, DO YOU CONCERN AS A
FEDERAL OFFICIALS, LAWMAKERS,
SOMEBODY WHO LEGISLATES THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THAT MAYBE
DIMINISHES THE IMPACT OF WHAT
THIS MOMENT IS AND KIND OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT'S HAPPENING,
AT LEAST IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
REACH A RESOLUTION ON ISSUES.
WELL IF JOE BIDEN IS INTERESTED
IN REACHING A RESOLUTION ON THE
ISSUE, LET HIM DEAL WITH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER. WE HAVE DRUGS
COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND THIS CRISIS THIS
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS THAT WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY HAS A
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP TO OUR DRUG
LAWS BEING LOOSENED AND THE LACK
OF FUNDING AT THE STATE LEVEL
FOR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. SO
LET JOE BIDEN DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE UNDERLYING
THE VERY SERIOUS AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU. MY HEART GOES OUT
EVERY TIME WE HAVE ONE OF THESE
SHOOTINGS TO THE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES OF THESE
SHOOTINGS, BUT IT DOESN'T IT
DOESN'T LESSEN THE BURDEN THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS IN FINDING
SOLUTIONS TO THESE PROBLEMS
OTHER THAN JUST BLAMING THE GUN
ALL THE TIME FOR THE PROBLEM
THAT HE, IN PART IS CAUSING BY
HIS POLICIES ON THE BORDER. SO
EVEN IF I STIPULATE EVERYTHING
YOU SAID, RELATED TO THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT'S THE BURDEN ON
YOU? AS A LAWMAKER? IN THE WAKE
OF THESE? YOU NOTED, EVERY TIME
ONE OF THESE HAPPENS, YOUR HEART
GOES OUT. YOU FEEL AWFUL. THE
FACT THAT THEY HAPPENED SO MANY
TIMES THAT YOU HAVE TO SAY EVERY
TIME THAT WOULD SEEM TO BE A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM
NATIONALLY. SO WHAT'S THE BURDEN
ON YOU? AS A FEDERAL OFFICIALS
LAWMAKER TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS? REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU
THINK IT IS, BUT TO DO SOMETHING
RIGHT? NO I ABSOLUTELY
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND MY BURDEN
IS TO MAKE SURE I FOLLOW THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE SECOND
AMENDMENT PROTECTOR OR MORE THAN
TWO MILLION R FIFTEENS. AS YOU
SAID, YOU HAVE SOME FRIENDS WITH
A R FIFTEENS THERE, NOT A DANGER
TO ANYBODY. THE IDEA THAT WE'RE
GOING TO CONFISCATE TWO MILLION
WEAPONS IN THIS COUNTRY IS PURE
FOLLY. THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GOING
TO BAN A PARTICULAR KIND OF
WEAPON AS IF SOME OTHER WEAPON
WON'T BE USED. I CAN REMEMBER.
20 YEARS AGO, THE BAND WAS ON
HANDGUNS. WE'VE GOTTA WE'VE
GOTTA STOP HANDGUNS FROM BEING
USED AND HANDGUNS KILL FAR MORE
PEOPLE THAN A RIFLE LIKE AN AR
15. IF YOU GO TO CHICAGO AND YOU
LOOK AT THE MURDER RATE IN SOME
VERY POOR AREAS OF CHICAGO,
THEY'RE NOT USING A R FIFTEENS
ARE USING HANDGUNS, SO
ULTIMATELY WE NEED TO STOP THE
VIOLENCE BY MAKING SURE WE TAKE
VIOLENT CRIMINALS OFF THE
STREETS AND ADDRESSING THE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE THAT WE
FACE. THAT'S MY BURDEN. CAN I
ASK YOU? I DO. WE ONLY HAVE A
FEW MINUTES LEFT. BUT I DO WANT
TO ASK YOU ABOUT TIKTOK. IT HAS
BEEN IN THE NEWS. YOU HAVE
OBVIOUSLY BEEN A LEADING VOICE
ON THIS ISSUE. THERE'S
BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT THAT TIKTOK
IS A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
YOU PERSONALLY HAD THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ACKNOWLEDGED THAT IT IS
A NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
YOU'VE INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD BAN THE APP
NATIONWIDE. BUT SOME TIKTOK
USERS SAY YOU'RE FOCUSING ON THE
WRONG ISSUE, PARTICULARLY IN THE
WAKE OF THE LAST 24 HOURS. TAKE
A LISTEN 20,138 DEATHS FROM
FIREARMS IN 2022, THE BEST THAT
CONGRESS CAN DO TO KEEP US SAFE
IS TO BAN TIKTOK. I'M SO GLAD
THAT WE HAVE ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO PROTECT US AND OUR CHILDREN.
I KNOW THESE ARE TWO SEPARATE
ISSUES. BUT WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE
? TIKTOK USERS HAVE CERTAINLY
ENGAGED RECENTLY TRYING TO GET
OUT IN FRONT OF THIS. WHAT'S
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT? IT WAS
THAT A TIKTOK VIDEO. BY THE WAY,
IT WAS SORRY, SIR. YES IT WAS.
IT'S KIND OF INTERESTING THAT
THAT TIKTOK WOULD PROMOTE A
VIDEO LIKE THAT TO TRY TO
DISTRACT PEOPLE FROM THE REAL
ISSUE. CHINA IS ACCUMULATING
DATA ON AMERICANS THAT ARE USING
TIKTOK. THAT DATA CAN BE USED IN
THE CYBER WAR. WE ARE ABOUT TO
HAVE A CONFLICT WITH CHINA OVER
TAIWAN, AND THERE MAY VERY WELL
BE CYBER WARFARE BETWEEN TWO
COUNTRIES. WE DON'T WANT TO GIVE
CHINA THE UPPER HAND IN THAT
REGARD. I UNDERSTAND THAT TIKTOK
IS POPULAR AND I UNDERSTAND IT.
IT IS A MUCH BETTER TECHNOLOGY
THAN INSTAGRAM OR OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE. WE CAN'T SELL OUR
TECHNOLOGY. FACEBOOK CAN OPERATE
IN CHINA. GOOGLE CAN'T OPERATE
IN CHINA. YET THESE COMPANIES
LIKE TIKTOK CAN ACCUMULATE DATA
TO BE USED AGAINST AMERICANS IN
THE FUTURE. IT'S A POLICY THAT
MAY NOT BE VERY POPULAR, BUT
IT'S VERY NECESSARY AND IT'S A
IT'S A BIPARTISAN ONE AS WELL.
AND CONGRESSMAN, YOU'VE BEEN ONE
OF THE LEADING VOICES ON